Have you ever wondered what made the
loudest sound on Earth?
To put things in perspective, let's start
small...
Breathing is around 10 decibels.
Light rain comes in at 40 decibels.
You get 70from a vacuum cleaner.
90 from a blender.
And a live rock band will produce around 120.
Thedecibel scale measures noise logarithmically.
For our non-mathematicians...
When a sound increasesfrom 10 decibels to 20 decibels, it becomes 10 times more powerful.
Going from 20 decibels to30 increases the power by 10 times again.
Once you get into the 150 decibel range, the soundbecomes powerful enough to rupture eardrums.
So you should stand well clear of a startingpistol at 140 decibels
or a rocket launch of 180.
And at 194 decibels, sound waves become shockwaves which can destroy nearby buildings.
But that's nothing compared to what happenedon the 27th of August 1883.
On the Indonesian island of Krakatoa, a volcanic eruption produced
what scientists believe to be the loudest soundrecorded in human history
at an estimated310 decibels.
It was reportedly heard in morethan 50 different locations
and the sound wavetravelled three and a half times around the planet.
For as many as five days after the explosion, weather stations observed an unprecedentedspike in pressure
recurring roughly every 34 hours
as it circled the globe.
It caused deadly tsunamis as far as Hawaii and South America;
major drops intemperature in the Northern Hemisphere,
and deeply tinted sunsets in the West.
Some scientistshave theorized that Edvard Munch's 'The Scream' depicts those vibrant orange skies.
Nothing inrecorded history has ever come close.